It's tasty, a little bit
squishy, totally delightful,
and even better if toasted.
My name is Rich
Hyndman, and I'm going
to delve into the fluffy center
of our latest Android offering
and the new hardware that
forms the latest Nexus lineup.
So Android Marshmallow.
Numerically, it's Android 6.
And for developers,
that's API 23.
It's the most stable, efficient,
and feature-packed version
of Android yet.
And the first two devices to
launch with the latest hotness
are the Nexus 5X and Nexus 6P.
The Nexus 5X is a delight
built in partnership with LG.
It's equipped with a
5.2-inch 1080p display,
a Snapdragon 808 processor, and
a 12.3-megapixel rear camera.
It offers top-of-the-line
performance in a compact,
lightweight device.
For developers, there were
two new intermediate densities
other than API 23.
Density 360 and density 420.
And the new Nexus 5X is
in that latter bucket.
So, for devs that are using
compatible screen declaration
in their manifest,
you're going to need
to test your app out
and add the new values.
The Nexus 6P, built with
Huawei, rocks a 5.7-inch
high-resolution
AMOLED display.
front-facing stereo speakers,
and a 12.3-megapixel rear
camera, all housed in a
contoured aluminum body.
I absolutely love these devices,
and both have USB-C ports
and fingerprint sensors.
The updates in
Marshmallow are primarily
targeted towards improving
the user experience,
smoothing out install
and update flows,
speeding up authentication,
improving battery life,
adding contextually
sensitive controls,
and allowing applications to
assist each other at a deeper
level than ever before.
Arguably one of the
biggest changes in M
has to be the arrival
of runtime permissions.
While this reduces friction
for install and updates,
it does come with some overhead.
You can no longer assume
just because your app
is installed that all its stated
permissions have been granted.
Permissions are now
granted at runtime,
and users can revoke permissions
on a per-app basis at any time.
There are more details
in Nick Butcher's video
on permissions UI.
In an effort to simplify robust
data backup for developers
and also simplify
the lives of users,
Android Auto Backup ensures
up to 25 megabytes of data
is backed up per app.
If your project
targets M, backup
will automatically be enabled.
And there are a couple of
things you should be aware of.
So be sure to check out the
docs and watch Matthew's video
for full details.
Something I'm
personally very excited
about-- There are
a number of battery
optimizations in Marshmallow.
But the biggest
individual contributors
are Doze and App Standby.
If a user leaves their device
unplugged and stationary
for a period of time
and the screen is off,
then the device is going
to enter Doze mode.
It's going to stay
in that sleep state
until the device is disturbed.
By default, some restrictions
apply to apps in this mode.
Wake clocks may be
ignored, scheduled alarms
can be deferred, and network
access may be disabled.
But if you have good
reason to wake your app,
then you can do so.
And Joanna Smith has
just released a video
explaining it all.
There are new authentication
and security possibilities
with the addition of the
fingerprint recognition APIs.
When you support an
adb testing command,
you can help your users have the
most secure device as possible.
Maya has the full
details in her video.
If you want to make it easy
for users to transition
from your web content
to your app content,
app linking lets you take
control of the web content
that you own.
And Wojtek has a video that
explains it beautifully.
On top of that, we have
Bluetooth stylus support,
tech selection, context-aware
pop-ups, adoptable storage,
and that Assist API which allows
you to integrate with services
built by other developers.
Not strictly part of
Marshmallow but definitely worth
mentioning is the
introduction of data binding.
It's an Android Studio
feature from 1.3 onwards,
and it reduces
the amount of code
you need to write
to hook up your XML
layouts with your activities.
See Neto's video
for the lowdown.
There have also been updates
to the support library
with a number of new
libraries including
custom tabs, percentage-based
layouts, recommendations,
and preferences.
With all the new goodness
comes some goodbyes.
First up, a deprecated
API has been removed.
Apache HTTP was
deprecated a while back
in favor of the more
efficient HttpURLConnection.
And it's been
removed in Android 6.
If your app or any of the
libraries you use rely on it,
you're going to need to make
a small update to include it
in your build and declare it
in your buildup Gradle file.
Even though OpenSSL was never
part of the public NDK API,
some apps still
linked against it.
And now that Android a switched
from OpenSSL to BoringSSL--
yup, that's the name-- it means
that those apps will now break.
If you're in this situation,
you need to get testing.
All the videos mentioned here
are available in our Android
Marshmallow playlist.
So that's Android Marshmallow,
something harmless
and lovable that could never
possibly run amok in New York
and destroy us.